vamos a empezar con nuestro sistema
clásico que hemos estado usando una y
otra vez y eso es porque tiende a ser
bastante útil para explicar este tipo de
sistemas y además es el más clásico que
se cubre en las clases en los libros por
ejemplo entonces tenemos este contenedor
que tiene un pistón que se puede mover
un techo que se puede mover digamos y
por supuesto tenemos dentro del sistema
un montón de moléculas o de átomos que
están rebotando por ahí creando algún
tipo de presión en el sistema ok
entonces digamos que tiene una presión p
1 y un volumen de aquí que tiene tiene
volumen de 1 y digamos que tiene también
cierta temperatura con la que empieza y
que todo está en equilibrio porque estos
macro estados solo se pueden definir de
esta forma la presión la temperatura y
el volumen solo se define se definen
perdón si están el sistema en equilibrio
entonces digamos que tiene una
temperatura de 1
para poder mantener fijo el pistón vamos
a poner piedritas no sea quizás arena ok
y por supuesto estoy haciéndolo en en
granitos muy pequeños porque quiero
removerlos lentamente porque vamos a
aproximar por procesos cuasi estáticos y
quiero aproximar este sistema digamos
que está bastante aproximado al
equilibrio para que podamos definir
nuestros macro estados la presión el
volumen la temperatura ok entonces en
este vídeo lo que quiero estudiar es lo
que llamamos procesos isotérmicos
procesos isotérmicos y lo que esto
significa realmente es que vamos a
mantener la temperatura igual entonces
eso significa igual y quizás cuando has
estudiado la tabla periódica
recordarás cuando hablamos de los
isótopos que son simplemente del mismo
elemento con distinta masa atómica
verdad entonces eso significa igual mi
pregunta es por qué cuando removemos
está esta arena digamos que es lo que va
a pasar si lo hiciera de esta forma
digamos sí sí sí simplemente si
estuviéramos aislados del mundo ok si
éste fuera un proceso diabético déjenme
escribir esto a diabético una palabra
bastante rimbombante significa diabético
que está completamente desolado es decir
está sin comunicación con el mundo
exterior es decir no hay entrada ni
salida de calor en este caso qué es lo
que pasaría si voy quitando
cada una de estas partículas y déjenme
copiar y pegarlo
aunque nada bueno vamos a dibujarlo
atrás entonces digamos tengo aquí un
muro una pared el suelo el otro muro y
al ir quitando un par de granitos
digamos de esta arena el volumen va a
incrementar verdad va a incrementar un
poco para incrementar un poquito y voy a
tener aquí menos granos de arena o de
piedras y como tengo el mismo número de
moléculas éstas van a rebotar cada vez
menos verdad así que la presión va a
bajar y el volumen va a subir si fuera
un proceso a diabético no tengo ningún
calor que se agrega al sistema lo que
cómo puedo conocer cómo se comporta la
temperatura bueno si sé que es cierto
trabajo se realizó verdad porque
teníamos nuestro techo que se movió
hacia arriba entonces aplicó cierta
fuerza y se generó cierto trabajo así
que cambiamos la energía cinética
transferimos energía cinética fuera del
sistema esto es esencialmente lo que
hace el trabajo verdad que la energía
cinética
se traduce en trabajo y la temperatura
es simplemente el más o menos el
promedio de la energía cinética de hecho
tenemos bueno ya no vamos a entrar más
en más detalle pero en el último vídeo
con la prueba que hicimos que quizás no
lo viste porque está bastante matemático
el asunto y no se trataría comúnmente en
las clases de química pero les demostré
que la energía interna es igual a tres
medios bueno esto es el total de la
energía cinética que es igual a tres
medios por el número de moles por la
constante r por la temperatura así que
este esto es esencialmente la
temperatura pero por cierto cierto
factor de escala entonces cuando hago un
trabajo estoy cambiando la energía
cinética del sistema ok entonces esto es
en un proceso a diabético no hay si no
hay calor agregándose al sistema el
calor
perdón la temperatura que es la energía
cinética esencialmente va a bajar
y de hecho sólo como un punto extra como
es la energía interna bueno la energía
interna del sistema podríamos escribirlo
en su fórmula original que el cambio en
la energía interna es igual al camión no
perdón dije que no iba a hacer eso
verdad simplemente es el calor baja
menos el trabajo hecho por el sistema
este es el trabajo hecho por el sistema
y por eso estamos restando pero esto es
a diabético así que no hay calor
entrando al sistema así que el el cambio
en el en la energía cinética es igual a
menos el trabajo hecho en esta situación
el sistema si realiza un trabajo verdad
al empujar el pistón hacia arriba así
que nuestra del tabú es negativa así que
y baja y eso tiene sentido porque si la
temperatura baja entonces la energía
interna del sistema también tiene que
bajar y para en el perdón sistemas
sencillos como el que estamos
representando siempre va a ser este el
caso es decir si la temperatura no
cambia la energía interna tampoco si la
temperatura sube la energía interna sube
temperatura baja la energía interna baja
y aunque no son exactamente la misma
cosa en realidad sólo varían por un
factor de escala que es tres medios por
el número de moléculas por r que es la
constante del gas ideal verdad así que
vamos bien hasta ahora fuimos a través
de todo este ejercicio sólo para mostrar
qué es lo que pasa con este sistema
aislado y que se removía estas estos
granitos la temperatura iba a bajar
ahora les dije también que íbamos a
hablar de procesos isotérmicos y lo que
quiero hacer en esto es hablar de los
procesos en donde la temperatura se
mantiene igual y bueno lo que voy a
hacer es poner este sistema arriba de lo
que podríamos llamar un depósito de
calor digamos así que este depósito
pueden imaginarlo como una una cantidad
infinitamente grande de algo que está a
una temperatura fija que digamos que es
de 1 así que incluso si tomamos dos
cosas
y digamos dos cosas que tengan un tamaño
distinto digamos un hay un b y digamos
que tienen una temperatura distinta
bueno lo que va a pasar es que se
obtiene el promedio verdad de sus
temperaturas pero si ves extremadamente
grande ya es sólo una pequeña partícula
digamos
no sé podríamos pensar que es polvo de
oro mientras que ves la torre eiffel
entonces esencialmente la ve no va a
cambiar verdad a simplemente se va a
volver de la temperatura debe así que
tuve
teóricamente podemos pensar está este
depósito de calor infinitamente grande y
a una temperatura fija ok entonces la
temperatura de este depósito es fíjate 1
y que además del proceso es diabético
excepto en el punto donde donde toca el
t 1 es decir ya no es un proceso a
diabético porque está en contacto con el
depósito así que cómo se va a ver
nuestro diagrama de presión volumen así
que vamos a dibujar el diagrama
en este eje en este eje vertical vamos a
poner la presión en este vamos a poner
el volumen así que digamos que si tengo
aquí mi punto inicial y lo que estoy
diciendo es que voy a hacer un proceso
isotérmico es decir voy a estar quitando
los granitos
de este estado vamos a ver a dónde llega
vamos a déjenme copiar y pegar porque ya
hicimos bastante arte en este dibujo ok
y entonces al ir quitando estas
partículas de arriba de estos granitos
digamos quitamos una buena porción de
ellos y vi y debido a ello va a
incrementar el volumen verde va a
incrementar el volumen digamos que va a
ponerse un poquito más arriba así que
algo que vamos a ponerlo ahí y debido a
que removimos estas partículas el
volumen sube y en la presión baja así
que como es un proceso que no es a
diabético porque la temperatura se va a
mantener constante a través de esta cosa
teórica que vamos a llamar depósito
debido a eso este estado va a viajar a
lo largo de una trayectoria que le
llamamos la isoterma
ok vamos a llegar a un punto por aquí
digamos al estado 2 1 2 y lo que estamos
afirmando es que esta trayectoria para
llegar del estado 1 al 2 va a ser una
especie de hipérbola ok es decir si
vamos agregando ahora al revés si vamos
agregando granitos esto se va moviendo
vamos completando la hipérbola igual si
vamos quitando y quitando más seguimos
completando esta hipérbola así que por
qué por qué ocurre esto bueno si si
mantengo la temperatura constante nos
vamos a mover a lo largo de esta
hipérbola pero vamos a tomar primero la
fórmula del gas ideal
si tomamos la fórmula del gasto ideal
tengo que pp es igual la nrc ok si te es
constante que es lo que estamos
suponiendo las otras dos letras son
constantes entonces sabemos que no que
no cambiamos el número de partículas
verdad finalmente tengo que por b es
igual a una constante ok y si queremos
describirlo como b ap perdón como
función debe es k sobre b ahora esto
puede que no te parezca muy familiar
pero si lo escribimos en términos
algebraicos ya sabemos que la gráfica de
igual a 1 entre x como se ve es es justo
la hipérbola equilátero verdad es decir
si estos son los ejes esto se ve de esta
forma ok eso en el primer cuadrante
y bueno cuando mantenemos la temperatura
constante estamos realmente escribiendo
una hipérbola recta rectangular baja
entonces si tenemos una baja temperatura
bueno tendremos alguna otra hipérbola
pero el punto es que todas son hiper
bolas quizás se ve a lo mejor de esta
forma con una temperatura distinta ok
por qué es eso bueno porque si tenemos
una temperatura menor para cualquier
volumen digamos tengo aquí un volumen
entonces tendremos una presión menor y
eso es por lo que y eso y eso ocurre
siempre que la temperatura sea menor que
por ejemplo ésta tf1 que con la que
iniciamos ok entonces en el proceso a
diabéticos y cambiaba la temperatura en
este estamos suponiendo que es un
proceso isotérmico así que no va a
cambiar la temperatura y en este vídeo
quiero que quede realmente entendido
como cómo vamos a trabajar con estos
estados isotérmicos ok entonces si nos
movemos a lo largo de esta curva
isoterma ésta
manteniendo la temperatura constante a
lo largo de esta hipérbola rectangular
entonces vamos a hacer un paso más vamos
a pensar cuál es el trabajo realizado
ajá por este por este proceso al viajar
de este estado al otro o si quieren
verlo en términos visuales si al ir
quitando granitos de arena vamos de este
estado 1
al estado 2 en donde el volumen se
incrementa es decir nuestra presión
disminuye verdad ok entonces vamos a ver
cuál es el trabajo y en algunos vídeos
anteriores vimos que el trabajo hecho es
el área debajo de esta gráfica verdad es
esta área debajo de esta de esta gráfica
o si queremos hacerlo en términos de
cálculo y de hecho voy a romper el
esquema de este vídeo porque vamos a
empezar con el cálculo así que si no te
interesa o no estás preparado aún puede
estar marta parte los oídos y los ojos
pero bueno vamos a quitar todo esto
quizás deberían anotar eso en el título
del vídeo pero bueno
usando cálculo
con la suposición de que la temperatura
se mantiene entonces bebé es igual la
nrc de donde concluimos que p es igual a
n rt sobre b es decir pasamos dividiendo
la b entonces ya está la presión como
función del volumen y es justo esta
gráfica que estamos poniendo aquí
podríamos escribir p como función debe
explícitamente pero lo que queremos ver
es el área debajo de la curva de desde
el volumen 1 digamos hasta el volumen 2
así que eso qué es lo que va a ser lo
que vamos a tener que hacer es integrar
desde b1 hasta de 2 igual es el trabajo
es igual a la integral de b1 b2 de la
presión como función del volumen verdad
y estamos integrando respecto al volumen
muy bien y simplemente vamos a sustituir
p verdad así que el trabajo es la
integral desde b1 hasta b 2 de nrc sobre
b sobre b
por dv muy bien ahora este es nuestra
suposición de que estamos colocando el
sistema sobre un depósito de temperatura
ajá que está transfiriendo la
temperatura a todo el tiempo y así se
mantiene a una temperatura de un nuevo
todo el tiempo así que si miramos esto
la temperatura en este caso es una
constante ok
así que podemos reescribir esta integral
simplemente como la integral de b1 b2 o
de 1 sobre b
dv y me faltó poner en rt acá afuera ya
que son constantes pueden salir de la
integral cual es la anti derivada de 1
sobre b bueno ese es el logaritmo
natural debe entonces el trabajo es
igual a n rt por el logaritmo natural
logaritmo natural de b y lo evaluamos de
v2 a b1 es decir vamos a hacer una resta
verdad esto es en
rt por por el logaritmo natural de 2
menos el logaritmo natural del b 1 ahora
sabemos de las propiedades del logaritmo
que esto es lo mismo que en rt x y la
resta del logaritmo se traduce en el
logaritmo de un cociente entonces nos
queda el logaritmo natural del b 2 entre
b 1 y ya tenemos calculado el valor real
de el trabajo realizado por este proceso
ya que b1 y b2 son constantes y
finalmente el trabajo el trabajo
realizado por este proceso isotérmico el
área debajo de la curva desde la curva
de la presión como función del volumen
es esto el nrc donde n es el número de
moles r es la constante desde el gas
universal de la temperatura fija b12 es
nuestro volumen final y de 1 es el
volumen inicial ahora déjenme
preguntarles lo siguiente cuánto calor
fue inyectado al sistema aquí en este
sistema isotérmico cuánto calor
agregamos y porque realmente agregamos
calor porque la temperatura de no
haberle agregado calor hubiera bajado
verdad entonces cuanto le agregamos
bueno como es un sistema isotérmico
entonces no hubo un cambio en la
temperatura y por lo tanto si no hay un
cambio en la temperatura la energía
cinética no cambia y por lo tanto la
energía interna no está cambiando y lo
que sabemos del cambio en la energía
interna es que el cambio en esta energía
es igual al calor que le agregamos al
sistema menos
o realizado por el sistema ahora si no
hubo un cambio en la energía interna
entonces del lado izquierdo tenemos cero
y esto es igual a q - w lo que es
equivalente a que q es igual a w es
decir que el trabajo realizado por el
sistema que es este de aquí y terminamos
que está en jules esto es igual al calor
que le ponemos al sistema entonces esto
es igual aquí cuando vemos esto si
fuéramos a dibujar esta parte de la
curva lo que déjenme dibujarla
nuevamente para que queden las cosas
bonitas quiero que queden muy claras
estos conceptos de la termodinámica ok
entonces empezamos en este estado 1 y
nos movemos a lo largo de este hipérbola
rectangular que es una isoterma al
estado 2
al estado 2 y ahora calculamos el área
debajo de esta curva que es el trabajo
realizado
entre el volumen 1 y 2 y que de hecho es
el nrc por el logaritmo natural de b 12
entre b 1 verdad aquí estamos ubicando
todo esto ok ya esto es solo el diagrama
presión volumen y en esta convención
esto es porque el trabajo lo realizamos
cuando la temperatura era constante es
decir que no cambia y teníamos que hay
que agregarle cierto calor para que eso
se conserve es decir para que la
temperatura sea constante algún calor se
le agrego al sistema a lo largo de ésta
isoterma ok de este proceso hizo térmico
y el valor q es equivalente al trabajo
que realizó el sistema es decir pusimos
el mismo calor como el trabajo que
realizó el sistema podríamos decir que
entonces la temperatura no cambia debido
a esto verdad
ok tienen que ser estas dos cosas
iguales de todos modos quiero dejarlos
con esto espero que ya tengan más
intuición de cómo funcionan los
diagramas de presión volumen los
procesos a diabéticos isotermo
y lo más importante es que a lo mejor
tenemos resultados muy matemáticos pero
que nos sirven mucho para darnos idea de
lo que ocurre en este tipo de sistemas
que estamos trabajando nos vemos